[موسيقى]
انا النهارده هكلمكم عن شيء انا بسميه
العذاب الجميل ما تستغربوش العذاب ممكن
فعلا يكون جميل طول ما احنا بعيد عن
الشايب الياسمين العذاب ممكن يكون فعلا
شيء كويس ممكن من الخوف الشديد البني ادم
يكون اكثر شجاعه ممكن من الجوع ومن العطش
البني ادم يكون اكثر قوه هو ده العذاب
اللي انا اقصده طول ما العذاب بدرجه معينه
وبحاجه معينه او باسلوب معين ممكن يبني في
شخصيه البني ادم ثم العذاب يوقعك وتقوم
انت بتبقى اقوى ما بتبقاش اضعف هو ده
العذاب اللي انا عايز اكلمكم عليه
النهارده القصه بدات معايا من سنه حوالي
تقريبا 2004 2005 بدات اسافر بره مصر بس
باسلوب مختلف طريقه مختلفه شويه عن
المنطقه المنتشره او الاسلوب المنتشر في
المنطقه العربيه سافرت اول سفريه للسودان
كان معروض عل ان انا اسافر كولومبيا
كولومبيا دي للناس اللي ما تعرفهاش بلد في
امريكا اللاتينيه القتل فيها تقريبا يوميا
تعرض عل ان انا اسافر كولومبيا ست شهور او
ان انا اسافر السودان ا اخترت السودان بس
كان بودني ان انا اروح كولومبيا بس
ماروحتش في لحظه ما لقيت نفسي باكل كافيار
خمس مرات في اليوم بالزبده وفي لحظه تانيه
لقيت نفسي بقعد على موائد الرحمن في
السعوديه لان معيش فلوس ان انا اكل في
لحظه كنت بقعد باليومين ما باكلش فعلا ما
باكلش نهائي معيش حتى فلوس اشتري اعيش
معيش فلوس ان انا اشتري اي شي خالص يومين
كاملين 48 ساعه ما باكلش ساعات كنت بقعد
اكتر بس اللحظه
دي اثرت علي قوي لحظه تانيه كنت بنزل
اشتريلي اطار 300 400 جنيه انزل اشتري
فنجان شوربه عشان بس اظبط مزاجي 75 جنيه
فيش مشكله بالنسبه لي لحظه كنت بمشي في
المستنقعات في الغابات الافريقيه
المستنقعات بتاع الملح مستنقعات بتاع
الطينه وفي لحظه تانيه كنتي فيلج روس وفي
لحظه تانيه بلاقي نفسي ماشي الشبه عريان ف
درجه حراره ناقص 20 هو مش ماشي كنت بجري
يعني ما كنتش
بمشي في لحظه
ما كنت بلاقي نفسي مرفوعه السكينه على
رقبتي مش سكينه هي حاجه اسمها جنبيه
الجنبيه دي حاجه قد كده عباره عن خنجر
بيشيلوا اليمنيين واحد فيهم حط الجنبيه دي
على رقبتي عشان يدبحني وفي لحظه تانيه
واحد حط المسدس في جنبي في جنوب السودان
المليشيات في جنوب السودان بتكره جدا
المصريين بتعتقد ان المصريين كانوا
بيساعدوا الشماليين في الحرب ضدهم لما
لقوني هناك في الادغال قبضوا عليا رفعي
الاول بالسلاح اخدوني المعسكرات بتاعتهم
حققوا معايا بعد كده سابوني في الاخر لما
اتاكدوا ان انا مش من مخابرات او مش من اي
شيء انا مجرد واحد عادي
كده في لحظه ما كنت ببقى نايم في
الادغال حواليا ناس كلنا حوالين بعض عشان
نحمي بعض عشان التماسيح بتطلع تاخد الناس
وتاخدهم يعني تاكلهم او مثلا تاكل منهم
رجل او تكل منهم ايدنا بق حوالين بعض عشان
نلحق الشخص قبل ما يتاكل بالكامل لحظه
اطريت انم في حاجه زي كده وفي لحظه ما كنت
بلاقي نفسي ان انا نايم في بيت او فندق
اثري في ارقى الفنادق في شمال تركيا في
لحظه
ما كنت بقى باشا كبير قوي في تركيا
المصانع بتتفتح لي مخصوص يوم الاجازه
العمال ينزلوا يشتغلوا في المصنع عشان
خاطري الناس كلها كانت بتيجي تحاول تخدمني
لحظه تانيه تقريبا بعديها بحوالي اسبوع
كان كل اللي بعمله في حياتي هو ان انا
ادلع الكلاب واغسل القطط واخد بالي من
الارانب واخد بالي من الحصان واغسله عن من
العماص وكنت بتمنى بس ان انا اشتغل طباخ
في الفتره دي او يعني الناس اللي انا قاعد
معهم يشغلوني طباخ مش اكتر
في لحظه ما اكون قاعد الصبح مع
واحد بيكون بيغني لا لا لا لا ازاي تعكسني
مالكش حق وبالليل اكون قاعد مع واحد تاني
بيقول بيت شعر تموت القصدي في البيداء
جوعه وترمى لحم الضق للكلاب ينام كل ذي
جهل على الحرير وينام كل ذي علم على
التراب اللحظات دي في حياتي اثرت فيا كتير
ولحظات تانيه كتير يعني ياما تعرضت للموت
ياما تعرضت لايام قلت انا مش هعيش
اه مره من ذات المرات في السودان كنت في
شاطئ شاطئ مهجور كنت معه واحد روسي اتقرصت
من سمكه ساما السمكه دي تقريبا اسمها عقرب
البحر او دجاجه البحر السمكه دي بتموت في
خلال نص ساعه بالظبط انا كان مفروض اكون
ميت بس اللي حصل ان انا
بحتجلك نفسه بموس بدات اشرط نفسي بالموس
بدات اربط الاماكن اللي اص فيها فيها
ا الحممد لله عشت ا لما واجهت حاجات زي
كده خليتني ابتدي افكر باسلوب مختلف في
لحظه
انيه شفت نفسي في اضعف الحالات شفت نفسي
خايف على وشك ان انا اعيط لما تهت في
الاحراش في اليمن في الجبال فعلا كنت على
وشك ان انا اعيط من كتر الخوف لان الاحراش
دي كان فيها حيوانات كان في حيوان مشهور
قوي اليمنيين بيتكلموا عليه كان اسمه
دحباش الدحباش ده تقريبا كان ا على ما
اعتقد من فصيله الفهود او من فصيله الذئاب
على الوصف كده اللي هم
بيوصفو اللحظات دي كلها اثرت جدا في حياتي
خليتني افكر باسلوب مختلف يمكن انا بتكلم
عليها كده باسلوب بسيط بس اللحظات دي لما
كانت بتعدي عليا كنت فعلا بعاني فعلا حس
ان انا ممكن اموت فعلا وجهت الموت اكثر من
مره مش مره واحده فعلا قلت ان انا ممكن ما
يعديش عليها نهار
كتير لكن الوضع بدا يختلف من سنه
2012 سنه 2012 دي كانت اخر مره سافرت برا
مصر كنت راجع من
تركيا الناس كنت
برسلهم بعتولي فيديو الفيديو ده كان عن
ايه الفيديو ده كان عن بنت يعني انا اسف
معلش هي كانت طفله شويه كانت تقريبا قريب
من السن اللي موجود 19 20 انا اسف طبعا
بقول حاجه ي كده بس انا عجوز
عليكم البنتت دي عملت حاجه ظريفه قوي البت
تقريبا كانت هولنديه او بريطانيه البنت دي
كانت شغاله في شركه جه المدير نكد عليها
عاشتها قعدت تعيط شويه وبعد كده قررت انها
تنتقل من كل حاجه راحت اي ثبت للمدير
وراحت رميه له استقاله وقرت انها تعمل
رحله بالعجله من اول بريطانيا لحد جنوب
افريقيا البنت دي دراعها اتكسر في الرحله
وكملت اتقرصت من العقارب وكملت البنت
دي يعني فكرتني بحاجات كتير قوي كانت سيئه
انا كنت متعايش بيها زي ايه اول رحله في
السودان خلتني اعرف حاجه مهمه قوي يعني
طبعا البيت ده او الكلمه اللي انا هقولها
دي علي انا مش على حد خلتني اعرف ان احنا
رجاله ولا تسوى رجاله اقل من النسو الكلمه
دي جت لي ازاي لما سافرت السودان شفت بنات
مش غربيات ده بنات من اسيا من اليابان شفت
بنات صغيره قوي البنات دي كانت بتعمل
حاجات انا ما كنتش اقادر اعملها فعلا انا
شفت بنت عندها 15 سنه كانت بتلف العالم
جايه من اثيوبيا على السودان انا كنت عامل
زي
اس زي الاهبل انا كان عندي 2 سنه كنت في
كليه هندسه راجل وهي بنت 15 سنه
طفله
افضل هنا عرف حت شخصيا محصلتش اي بنت
بره حاات
قوق هنا كنت متعايش مع العار هو احال احنا
رجاله اقل من
النسول مختلف بدات
افكر ان انا عايز انهي القصه دي على الاقل
حتى وان انا احاول ان انا احصل السيدات
بره يعني مش الرجاله السيدات احصلهم بس
يعني حتى مش اسبقهم لا احصلهم
بس قررت ان انا اعمل رحلات بالعجل مش زي
ما البنت عملت لان ظروف حياتي ماتسمحليش
ان انا اعمل حاجه زي كده بس شيء قريب يعني
شيء يسمحلي ان انا احس جوه داخليا ان انا
يعني مش اقل قوي من النسو يعني اقل حاجه
بسيطه يعني تمام ا بعديها بكم يوم اشتريت
عجله بدات اول رحله ل هي جوه مصر انا كنت
بعمل رحلات بالعجل بره مصر بس ماكانش
بالهدف ان انا اسافر كنت بس كده يعني كنت
عايز اروح البحر اروح خايم يومين ثلاثه مش
عارف ايه كده لكن جوه مصر كانت اول رحله ل
سنه 2012 شهر 10 رحت السويس كنت مع واحد
صاحبي السويس رايح جاي من بيتي من مدينه
مصر حوالي 240 كيلو رايح جاي يعني المسافه
الكليه قعدنا لاث ايام انا تعبت جدا جدا
في الرحله دي وبعد ما رجعت من الرحله
ا ركبتي ما كانتش قادره تشلني يعني عذرا
لما كنت بدخل حمام ما كنتش بقدر حتى اقعد
على القاعده بسبب ان ركب مش قادر اشن ما
كنتش بقدر امشي ماكنتش بقدر اعمل حاجات
كتير قوي بسبب الاجهاد اللي انا عملته في
الرحله دي
ماكسرتش قررت ان انا اكمل شيء تاني افضل
او شيء تاني اقوى بعديها بشهرين كنت مخطط
لرحله جديده الرحله دي كان هدفها ان احنا
نروح قطاع غزه بالعجل في يناير شهر يناير
في
الشتاء وكان ليها اهداف تانيه من ضمنها ان
احنا
نثبت ان ما فيش شيء ممكن يوقف البني ادم
لا فلوس ولا امكانيات ولا حتى الاشاعات
اللي الناس بتقعد تقولها ولا حتى الافكار
المجتمعيه اللي موجوده وفعلا اطلقت نداءات
على الانترنت في ال جروبس هنا انضم ل ثلاث
اشخاص بدانا الرحله دي اربع اشخاص اتجهنا
في اتجاه سينا مشينا من القاهره اسماعيليه
اسماعيليه عدينا القنال ان القنال انطرى
الشرق
بلوظه السادات البردويل العريش رفح قطاع
غزه اترفض ان احنا نخش قطاع غزه مدخلناش
رحنا راجعين رعنا تاني رفح العريش ل وصلنا
العريش بقيت لوحدي الاربعه كلهم كانوا كل
واحد كان مشي سبب
ما قررت ان انا اكمل الرحله كلها بالكامل
لحالي من العريش رحت داخ على وسط سينا حته
اسمها الحسنه نخل من نخلت طال على خليج
العقبه
نويبع نويبع الدهب
الشرب راس محمد التور ابو زنيبه وابو رديس
وراس سدرفي الاخر السويس ورجعت الرحله دي
قعدت 17 يوم انا كان نفسي ان انا اثبت
لنفسي ان انا اقدر اعمل رحله افضل من
الغربيين عامه واقوى منهم ما كنتش قادر
اعمل مسافه عشان بس اخليكم تفهموا القصه
الست بره ممكن تعمل رحله بالعجله فوق ال
الف كتر الراجل بره بيعمل رحلات بالعجله
بتوصل 400000 كل في سنين يعني بيقعدوا
سنين يعملوا الرحلات دي انا ما اقدرش اسيب
حياتي كلها سنين ماقدرش اسيب اهلي كلهم
سنين فتره كده
اا عايز اعمل رحله اقل شويه بس تكون رحله
قويه الرحله دي كانت رحله قويه جدا صحيح
ما عملتش مسافه عاليه لكن حققت انجازات من
نوع اخر اول انجاز كان في التكلفه خليني
اعد لكم تاني انا رحت فين وقعدت كام يوم
انا قعدت 17 يوم في الرحله دي قاهره
اسماعيليه
قناه السويس ديناها انطره شرق بلوظه
السادات بردويل العريش رفح بتاع غزه رفح
العريش بير الحسنه نخل نويبع دهب شارب راس
محمد بعد كده طور ابو زنيبه وابو رديس
وصدر والسويس 17 يوم 14 مدينه مختلفه
تفتكروا انا اتكلفت
كام وع فكره ده انجاز يعني انا اكتر واحد
سمعته على النت انا كسرت الرقم بتاعه كان
واحد غربي يعني يصرف فلوس في الانترنت انا
كنت كسرت الرقم بتاعه فانا بسالكم دلوقتي
تفتكروا انتوا لو هتعملوا رحله زي كده 17
يوم تعدوا فيها على 14 مدينه تتصرفوا
كام كام
7000 نعم اقل ها في ناس تقول 7000 تصرفوا
انتم
كام
كمم
جنيه ماشي عندنا 100
جنيه
انا صرفت 200 جنيه بالضبط 195
جنيه اقل رقم في الرحلات بره اللي
بيعملوا الدول القويه مثلا زي الدول
الغربيه او الدول في اسيا اقل رقم انا كنت
اعرفه كان حوالي 5 دولار من 3ه ل 5 دولار
يعني ده الرقم الرهيب البني ادم بيصرف 3
دولار تمام في اليوم ده يعني كانوا
بيعتبروه البطل بتاع العالم كله يعني اللي
بيصرف 3 دولار في اليوم في المتوسط يعني
تمام انا كسرت الحاجز ده بمنتهى البساطه ا
بس عشان اعمل كده كان في تمن انا نمت في
الشوارع نمت في الجناين نمت في مساجد نمت
جنب معسكرات الشرطه ناس استضفت ني
ماعرفهاش نمت في الاكواخ بتاعه البدو بدو
في الشمال وبدو في الجنوب ونمت عند ناس
انا ماعرفهاش نهائي ما كنتش متخيل ان انا
اقابلها في يوم من الايام ا نمت في حتت
كتير قوي تدع ذكراها كلها ولكن كل ادر لكم
ان انا نمت في اباكي كتير اتعذبت جامد قوي
كنت بحس بالبرد انا كنت في يناير في يناير
في سينا معرفش هدخل فيه عن درجات الحراره
هناك ولا لا بس في ثلج في سينا بينزل انا
شفت الثلج في نخل بس ما بيتش في نخل الحمد
لله ا كنت ببرد كتير ما كنتش بنام كنت
ساعات بقعد انام ثلاث ساعات بس لاني بنام
على الارض انا معايا الخيمه بتاعتي فانا
بنام في الخيمه البرد بيطلع لي من تحت
الارض فكنت بنام ثلاث ساعات ده اقصى حاجه
بنام الا لو حد اضفني ونمت في البيت بتاعه
لكن طول ما انا كنت ببقى نايم في الخيمه
ببقى نايم يا دوبك ثلاث ساعات بعد كده طول
الليل بفضل افف كده من البرد ما كنتش بنام
نهائي
ا ما كنتش بستحمى
نهائي انا كنت زمان بسمع من اصحابي اللي
بيشتغلوا في السياحه يقول لك الاجانب دول
يعني عذرا ناس راحتها مش ظريفه ناس ما
بتستحماش ما كنتش فاهم الاجانب ليه
بيعملوا كده لحد ما اتحطيت في الموقف ما
بقتش بستحمى مش لاني ما بحبش استحمى ا بس
انا ما كنتش بستحمى بسبب ظروفه ما كانش في
كان استحمى ما كانش في وقت ان انا استحمى
كنت استحمى فين انا واحد نايم في الشوارع
هستحمى فين بالظبط ما كنتش بستحمى اول مره
استحميت في الرحله دي كانت بعد 10 ايام
وعايز اقول لكم ان الحموم ده نعمه يمكن
كتير ما يعرفهاش بس كان عارفها واحد زي
واحد كان كل يوم بيقطع بالعجله حوالي على
الاقل 70 كم شايل على العجله حوالي 30
كيلو مثلا في اقصى الحالات بيفضل ماشي
بيعرق جامد جدا كل يوم ما بينامش بيفضل
قاعد كده طول الوقت ياكل اكل سيء يشرب
حاجات سيئه جدا
بس النهايه لما استحميت عايزكم ان انا
حاسس احساس محستوش قبل كده لما استحميت
بعد ع ايام كنت بني ادم
جديد بس من ضمن الصعبات اللي كانت في
الرحله الرحله كان فيها صعوبات تانيه وان
فيها اهداف تانيه طبعا اح نجحنا ان احنا
نثبت ان احنا ممكن نعمل رحله رخيصه يعني
عايزين نثبت للشباب ان الفلوس ماتوقفش لا
العجله متوقفش كان في معان شاب وصل مع لحد
رفح الشاب كان رايح بعجله نص العجله النصر
دي اللي هي ارخص عجله موجوده في مصر كان
في شاب وصل بيها
لحد رفح لحد البوابه بتاعه رفح بس بعد كده
رجع تمام ا ما تخليش الاشاعات اللي في
المجتمع توقفك بمعنى ايه بمعنى ان كان قبل
ما نبتدي الرحله كانوا كلهم بيقولوا لنا
البدو هيروق البوليس
هيبهدلك هتتقلب هتذبح في حتت في سينا
الحته دي فعلا حقيقيه في قبائل في سينا
كانت بتاخد الناس وتاجر في الاعضاء
البشريه بتاعتها سمعت كلام كتير بس انا
طنشت
ا ودي يعني يمكن من ضمن الحاجات اللي انا
كنت عايز اوصلها لكم النهارده مش لازم
تعيش في القوقعه اللي الناس رسمها لك لا
لو فضلت تستسلم للاخرين والكلام بتاعهم
الكلام اللي المنتشر في المجتمع هتطلع في
جلباب ابي بنفس الاسلوب بتاع المجتمع
بتاعك عشان تغير المجتمع بتاعك لازم انت
تبتدي تكون انسان مختلف تتحرك باسلوب
مختلف تعمل حاجات هم مابيعملهاش تعمل
حاجات حتى بره تفكير اي شخص هو ده في نظري
انا شخصيا التفكير بره الاطار الحقيقي
التفكير بره القوقعه اللي المجتمع بتاعك
راسمها لك انا معتقد ان احنا نجحنا ان
احنا نرسم القصه دي كان في هدف تاني
للرحله دي برض نجحنا فيه كان الهدف ان
احنا ندي محاضرات او انا شخصيا كنت بدي
محاضرات مجانيه للناس طول ما انا ماشي كنت
بدي محاضرات في حاجه اسمها لينكس ا كل بلد
كنت بخيم فيها كنت بحاول ادي فيها لينكس
اديت محاضرات لينكس في اكواخ بتاعه بده
وانا بدي المحاضرات لقيت بدو ما شاء الله
عليهم تبارك الله يعني لقيت بدو بيشتغلوا
في حاجات ها انا مهندس
كبيوتر ده حاجه على الكمبيوتر فكانوا
بيدوا في حاجات او كانوا كاتبين كتب انا
لقيت واحد بدوي الراجل ده كان كاتب كتاب
حاجه اسمها كيي دي في شركات في مصر اصلا
بتشتغل بها غير اربعه انا مافتش خالص
شركات في مصر بتشتغل بها غير اربع شركات
من اكبر شركات مصر حد بشتغل ب خص الج ده
كان كاتب كتاب كنت قاعد معاه في اللينكس
فكوخ كنا بناخد محاضره في الوخ وهو كان
بدوي اسمه استاذ محمد عوده انسان محترم
جدا ضمن الناس اللي لبستها
اي اديت في
نوادي اديت في جامعات في
العريش اديت في بيوت بدو في حته تانيه
اديت لناس نوعيه مختلفه المصريه مش فتاش
قبل كده كانت نوعيه في خليج العقبه نوعيه
من المصريين اللي هم منفتحين قوي كانوا
اوروبيين او كانوا بالنسبه لي انا
اوروبيين تمام واحد مثلا قال لي بقوللك
ايه تعال بات معايا بس انت هتقعد قصاد
البيات قالها لي كده على طول قصاد البيات
هتبتدي تسطب لي لينكس وتعلمني اللينكس
اوكي مافيش مشكله يلا طيب ولما دخلنا
البيت سابني وراح ماشي يا عم مش خايف ان
انا اسرع حاجه قاللي لا تكت ايزي قال انا
كنت عايش في المانيا وجوز واحده المانيه
فعلا كان هو الراجل عايش حياه كده بطريقه
مختلفه يعني تمام شفت ناس كتير قوي اتعذبت
قوي في الرحله دي لدرجه ان انا لما روحت
قعدت حوالي اسبوعين مش قادر اتكلم مع حد
من كتر البهدله اللي انا شفتها من كتر قله
كتر البرد اللي انا شفته من كتر القلق كتر
الخوف في بعض الاحيان هو ما كانش خوف قوي
بقدر ما هو كان قلق قلق من ايه قلق من كل
شيء قلق من البدو ممكن يعم معايا البدو
طلع عليا مرتين مره منهم كانت الساعه
حوالي 9عه بالليل كنت في الطريق من ذهب
للشرم السياحه كانت واقفه ماكانش في اي
شيء خالص ماشي في السياحه ما كانش في
اتوبيسات ما كانش في اي شيء فكنت ماشي
الساعه 9 بالليل و ادرك ما تعه بالليل في
سينا تعه بالليل في الطريق ده كان كله هوا
هوا عنيف جدا طبعا ظلمه مافيش ضلمه يمكن
احنا ما شفناش هنا الظلام لا الظلام في
الصحرا بيبقى من نوع مختلف طلعوا عل البدو
حاولوا ياخدوا مني العجله بالعافيه بس
ربنا سطر باسلوب معين طلع عليه البدو برض
قبل العريش
ا كان لي بعض الاحتكاكات مع البوليس طبعا
بطبيعه الحال البوليس مره دخل عليا الخيمه
وانا نايم بالليل راح فاتح الخيمه الساعه
10 بالليل وراح داخل عليا كانان لي
احتكاكات تانيه كويسه البوليس كان مثلا في
كمين المفارق كان
لما تفهموا القصه اللي انا بعملها قالو لي
طب تعال اتفضل عندنا وكل واشرب ونام وخد
دش كده وريح تمام انا طبعا مقدر ان هم
كانوا بيبقوا قلقانين ماشافوش حاجه زي كده
قبل كده فكنت مقدر قلق البوليس وقلق الناس
خاصه في منطقه سياحيه زي نويبع او خليج
قصدي خليج العقبه تمام بعد الرحله دي
ماتكسرتش قررت ان انا اعمل رحله تانيه
رحله اقوى شويه
اه الرحله الثانيه كان
من او كانت مفروض تكون بتلف حوالين مصر
كلها كنت قعد فيها لاث اشهر لاث اشهر دول
كانوا في الصيف الصيف اللي فات 2013 الناس
هنا في مصر كانت عماله تحضر لحاجات سياسيه
معينه ومشاكل ومظاهرات وانا كنت عمال الف
بالعجل قدي محاضرات
لينكس طلعت من القاهره العين السخنه العين
السخنه طلعت في اتجاه الزعفرانه
الغردقه سفاجه
القصير مرص علم مرص علم طالع
على برانيس او تقريبا برانس كده حلايب وم
حلايب رحت طالع على اسوان ومن اسوان رحت
نازل ابو سمبل وكان اول معبد في حياتي
اخشه كان ابو سمبل بعد كده ج جعت اسوان
ومن اسوان رحت طالع لقصر من لقصر رحت رايح
ان ومن ان كانت المشاكل في مصر زادت قوي
فكانوا اهلي قلقوا يعني بالزياده لا لازم
ترجع قوا ان الصعيد يحصل فيه قبان قلقوا
من المنطقه اللي احنا فيها دلوقتي ان يحصل
فيها مشاكل فيلا لازم ترجع فانا ركبت
القطر من هنا بعد ما لفيت قعدت شهر كامل
ا زرت جميع الاثار السياحيه اديت عدد كبير
جدا من المحاضرات كميه ضخمه جدا من الناس
اديت في نقط اسعاف اديت في بيوت اديت في
معاهد في جمعيات في جوامع
اه اديت في الشوارع اديت محاضرات نمت في
اماكن كتير قوي شفت ناس كويسه كتير وشفت
بعض الناس سيئه شفت درجه حراره بشعه شفت
56 شفت حاجه اسمها رياح السموم رياح الجيب
العمه مشيت فيها لوحدي طريق يا ابو سمبل
قعد ممان ساعات ماشي لوحد
تقريبا بسبب الشمس الرهيبه كان في شمس
ا بس في النهايه وصلت اللي انا كنت عايز
اعمله صحيح الرحله كلها ما نفعتش او ما
نجحتش لكن قدرت اوصل لنا كله او كل اللي
انا كنت عايز اثبته اثبته لنفسي اثبت ان
قدرت احصل الستات الى حد ما يمكن تفوقت
حتى عليهم وقدرت احصل الرجاله انا ما
سمعتش ابدا عن راجل ا سواء في الغرب او في
الشرق قدر يعمل رحله بالكيف دي بالظروف دي
في درجه الحراره
دي عشان كده قررت ان انا اعمل رحله تانيه
الرحله دي هتبتدي في خلال اسبوعين او
ثلاثه بالكتير ان شاء الله من مصر للسودان
الرحله دي انا بدعوكم ان انتم تنضموا ل
فيها
ليه عشان العذاب الجميل
الرحلات دي كلها ن استفدت منها شيء مهم
[تصفيق]
قوي انا استفدت حاجات يمكن تكون غريبه
عليكم شويه انا بقيت انسان متواضع ليه لما
شفت
نفسي شبه بعيط في اليمن من الخوف عرفت ان
اخرني يعني اخري ان اقعد
اعيط لما شفت الجوع وشفت حاجات كتير قوي
تعبت نفسيا منها
اه فعرفت اخري ايه فبقيت انسان متواضع
صحيح عرفت ان انا اقدر اتحمل حاجات كتير
بس برض عرفت ان انا ماقدرش اغمل بس بحاول
بحاول ان انا دايما اعذب نفسي بس الاسلوب
ما يكسرني اسلوب اقدر اقوم بعد كده بعديه
وهي دي كانت رسالتي ليكم النهارده واتمنى
ان انتم تشرفوني ان شاء الله في الرحله
بتاعه مصر الاستكر
جدا